glaucon gets so excited in this image he
says
take me out there take me every step of
the way show me the idea of the good
don't shut up until we see the idea of
the good and socrates says i'm sorry i
can't take you there
in fact i've never been there i don't
know what it's like but i know it exists
[Music]
that's philosophy
you've got to make the journey yourself
socrates next gives us the image of the
allegory of the cave let's imagine for a
moment that
uh this is a cave
and socrates says imagine there were
people sitting in the cave chained to
the ground looking at the wall at the
bottom of the cave
and then he suggests that there's some
path up the cave and there are more
people
up here and they're holding things like
an apple maybe
and there's a fire behind them
and the fire casts light onto the image
and so the people in the bottom of the
cave only see the image cast by the fire
under the wall of the cave they don't
actually see the apple
and then outside the cave we've got
puddles and trees
maybe with real apples on them
and
at the very top the sun
now
socrates puts this into a drama
and he first says okay those prisoners
down at the bottom of the cave
they're like us
and
that's perplexing how are we like
prisoners he says we are bound
that's something to reflect on the
chains that prevent us from looking at
the truth of things
vanity
fear
pride
so many things in our nature
that attach us to the things that we
think we know are true and prevent us
from making the turn
so socrates asks us to imagine
what it would be like if someone's
chains were broken and they were forced
to turn around and make their way up to
the next level of the cave
what's that experience like when you're
in a dark room and someone flips on the
light it hurts it's painful
but the pain is not a bad pain because
it's better to be in light than it being
dark but sometimes a reaction is to want
to stay in the dark
socrates beautifully describes uh
education as a breaking of the chains
and a turning of the soul that's a
language you use all education is
turning it's not putting knowledge into
a brain that's not there it's turning
the interior of the soul so it can see
correctly what a beautiful image for
education and this image by the way is
an image of edu of education of liberal
education
our very word education is from this
image in plato's republic a duke ray to
lead out from
the cave
so the prisoner
is dragged into the next level and sees
the next level of people holding these
images and casting the shadows on the
wall they are the image makers
image makers
who are the image makers
who are the image makers in our own
culture
think about it
i assume that you've seen commercials
before
how do they work
image makers
they cast images the nice car
the nice
clothing
casting images into our souls to do what
to help us reimagine reality a different
way and to then desire those things that
are being cast
think at a deeper level about the very
language we use and then i want you to
think about this
how deeply our contact with reality is
mediated by the images we've gotten but
socrates wants to suggest to us that
all of knowledge in some sense involves
interpreting reality through images but
then the question is do the image makers
actually
know enough
to make the images
what is the goal do we want these
prisoners to see reality as it is
or are we manipulating
do you see that the whole
area of this part of the cave
could be
a
a layer of just pure
manipulation
but socrates says no there's more
keep going
we can get outside the cave and now
we're ready for it it hurts this time
because the sun is a lot brighter than
the fire
philosophy is the movement from those
images to things to the forms to the
idea of the good philosophy is the love
of the thing at the top here the idea of
the good itself and socrates tells us
about the break in the chains he says
imagine if the philosopher were to go
back in to the cave and tell the
prisoners hey you guys would not believe
what i just saw
what do you think the prisoners do
hey take us let's go
some of them might but most of them say
you're talking nonsense
stop undermining our
beliefs about these images on the wall
this is socrates's account when the
prisoner who'd been released keeps
telling them they threatened to kill him
[Music]
wow
threaten to kill him
in other words the cave is like the city
of athens
the cave is like any city
all political regimes are somewhat
cave-like
all of us are prisoners in some sense
all of us see images and we want to make
that journey how do we make it that's
philosophy you've got to make the
journey yourself
[Music]
you